Ніколи ми Харков не здамо це дурниц все
Харків як був є і буде завжди
українським і європейським містом не
потрібно це знаєте кожного разу жувати
жувати жувати ні все ну прийде час всі
перейдемо на українську мову війна дуже
багато перевернула в ментальності
харків'ян Харків до початку війни
ментально і Харків сьогодні - це різний
Харків ці дадуже важко сказати що це
люди які наводять
ракети коли вбивають
людей важко їх назвати людьми до якого
2024 року ви готуєтесь Я повинен вам
казати правду початок року буде дуже
складний сьогодні спілкуємося з міським
головою Харкова Ігором тереховим Пане
Ігоре Вітаю вас вітаю ми зараз з вами
спілкуємося в кабінеті вашому але не у
міськраді тому що туди був приліт під
час повномасштабної війни Кажуть що у
вас є кілька офісів в час війни для чого
вони вам потрібні Ну насправді так і є
На жаль сьогодні я не можу
розташовуватися в одному приміщенні в
одному офісі і ви знаєте що був
приліт в мерію в минулому році нажда на
жаль постраждала мамерія крім цього я
певний час знаходився в од неї будівлі
потім біля неї були прильоти
с300 бо на жаль
сьогодні є певна Охота за мною як
міським головою і це я розумію тому мені
рекомендували щоб було декілька офісів
наразі на території Харківщини ведуться
тяжкі бої на фронті поблизу Куп'янська в
цих умовах яка роль Харкова що
стосується ролі Харкова то велика ро
роль Харкова бо ми приймаємо вимушених
переселенців Вчора я був в одному з
гуртожитків де були вимушено переселенці
з Куп'янська і діти з Куп'янська і ми
обслуговуємо людей і надаємо все послуги
і навчаємо дітей і працевлаштовуємо цих
людей які були вимушені переїхати бо в
них нічого нема тому для нас дуже
важливо сьогодні і це до речі не тільки
скупнська сьогодні у ркова перебуває 191
000 вимушених переселенців це
статистичні дані і це Донецька область
Луганська область запарізька область
Херсонська область де окупована
територія чи спілкуєтесь ви наразі з
військовими про можливу загрозу для
самого міста Харків в даних умовах що
стосується загрози для Харкова то ми
знаєте я не мо може ска казати що у
росіян в голові і ніхто не може сказати
і не головне які в них плани головне які
в плани у нас і ніколи ми Харков не
здаму е це дурниц все Харків як був є і
буде завжди українським і європейським
містом це головне і ми відстояли Харкові
і будемо відстоювати його у дослідженні
нещодавному форbс Харків потрапив у
список міст які взагалі не виділяють
бюджетних коштів за статтею саме
тероборони за це на міськраду на вас
особисто посипалася критика от Поясніть
нам нашим глядачам за якою логікою в
цьому році відбувається фінансування
збройних сил України на сьогодень ми за
цей період який з пер січня 23го року по
теперішній час видалили от сьогодні
494 млн і це кошти це палива це
матеріали які необхідні для військовим
але я хочу сказати що я спілкуюсь
постійно же з військовими і ви знаєте що
коли з'явилась ця публікація наша
славетна 92 Бригада мострілкова Бригада
яким ми допомагаємо грошима вони
виставили у себе на сторнцях обурення
тим що що трапилось дійсно Я вважаю що
це помилка не хочу це коментувати більш
хочу сказати що ми перераховуємо кошти
тіки с согодні платіж 10 млн ми
перерахували і будемо перераховувати
незважаючи на військові частини Ми
домовились Так що ми даємо кошти Ми не
купуємо купують самі військові бо вони
розуміють що їм потрібно зараз негайно
потрібно А ми виділяємо кошти а чи
підтримуєте ви нещодавно ухвалено
ініціативу про обов'язкове вилучення з
місцевих бюджету ось цієї оцього
військового ПДФО цієї час на потреби ЗСУ
Ми повинні розуміти що йде війна Я
відношусь до вилучення цього ПДФО по
державницькому і вважаю що сьогодні якщо
ми не будемо перераховувати це ПДФО на
військових так то у нас не буде
можливості
сьогодні більш швидше перемогти ваш
колега міський голова Києва Віталій
Кличко нещодавно в німецькому вдані
дершпігель дав таке інтерв'ю де заявив
що Україна цитую рухається до
авторитаризму демократія перебуває під
загрозою На його думку цитата чиниться
величезний тиск на органи місцевого
самоврядування як мер Харкова чи
відчуваєте ви от подібний такий тиск з
боку центральної влади ви знаєте я
декілька разів спілкувався з як ви
кажете з моїм
колегою мером міста Києва і у нас точки
зору щодо цієї пробле матики
Відрізняються один над одного ми
спілкувалися в Сполучених
штах на цю тему я не бачу сьогодні не
бачу сьогодні що є якесь знаєте давління
на демократію чи органи місцевого
самоврядування навпаки хочу сказати що
ми маємо безпрецедентно підтримку
сьогодні і уряда і нашого президента
Володимира Зеленського і офіса
президента е сьогодні нам допомагають
харків- прикордонне місто і сьогодні нам
не до політики не до політики і То що
нас підтримують
це головне Як часто ви як мер Харкова на
зв'язку з офісом президента з
Володимиром Зеленським про кого згадали
ну Останній раз я спілкувався під час
його візиту в місто Харків це було
минулого тижня чи Тиждень тому
вот був такий серйозно Розмова була
конструктивна дуже розмова хочу до речі
сказати що кожного разу коли я спілкуюсь
е ми дуже конструктивно розмовляємо і
після цього е певні шаги певні кроки
робляться І знаєте Не не було таких
питань Яке би ми не ставили і щоб вони
не вирішились ну щодо вищого політичного
керівництва України західні аналітики
припускають ніби є певний політичний
розкол між офісом президента і між
головнокомандувачем це залужним ви як
людина в політиці з досвідом всередині
цієї системи чи відчуваєте якісь
непорозуміння в нашому політикумі от в
цьому контексті
дивиться знаєте
з засобами масової інформації
telegramканали щось
кажуть правда чи чи неправда Я хочу
сказати що у мене нема такої інформації
більш того те що я бачу
то взаєморозуміння і під час війни повне
взаєморозуміння
і як я бачу Довіра один до одного тому
як до мене це знаєте певні провокації
які сьогодні існують на цю тему І я б
дуже не хотів би щоб знаєте ці
провокації продовжувалось ви самого пана
залужного особисто знаєте Ну так робочи
військови моментом ми ми обговорюємо є е
можливість зв'язатися задати питання
один одного
ее допомогти один одному Так це важливо
Сьогодні я на контакті із залужним із
сирським і з нашими
військовими зі всіма бо інакше неможливо
от залужний в нашій історії йому вже
досить багато присвячували характеристик
епітетів як людині військовій у цей
тяжкий час
Як би ви описали його ну
знаєте Я хочу сказати що він же каже що
головне що що йому не буде йому не буде
соромно так і Цем все сказано сьогодні
кожний на своєму місці
президент залужний
сирський офіс президента Андрей
борисовичєрмак левич колева усі всі
працюють сьогодні кожного кожної хвилини
кожного дня для того щоб е весь цей е
державний механізм функціонував
військовий механізм функціонував наразі
очільника СБУ Харківщини е пана Дудіна
Так його наразі судять по справі у
держзраді в той день 24 лютого коли вас
і очільника Харківської ОВА пана
сінігобова виводили з приміщення Ова це
було на відео ви вже тоді розуміли мета
дій
дивиться щодо зради
так то це може сказати тільки суд е я не
можу зараз коментувати це бо йде як ви
казали судове засідання йде тому хочу
сказати що коли буде вирок тоді я буду
казати
бо у мене є особиста точка зору щодо
нього пан дудін на своїх промовах під
час судових
засідань критикував висловлювався щодо
вас пана сінігубова цитата звинувачує
вас і каже що в тюрмі вас дуже чекають
що ви відповідаєте на на ці звинувачення
на цю його поведінку слухайте внни мема
виставляв після приїзду президента мені
показували їх некоректно як я як я
дивлюся
знаєте Ну як до мене хвора люди коли
говорять про явище колабораціонізму
українців в тому числі політиків з РФ
маю на увазі під час війни не
поодинокими є от реальні кейси з
Харківщини борівська вовчанська відома
Куп'янська громада наведення російських
ракет у селі гроза в чому причина цього
явища це явище яке не
сьогодення воно
зароджувалось ще десятиріччя тому
коли були Як я
розумію проводилась
вибовка людей коли
їм вбивалося у мозок що
Знаєте Радянський Союз що це Росія що
потрібно щоб так було щоб не потрібно
було щоб було НАТО щоб ці демократичні
процеси не
відбувалися хтось піддався хтось не
піддався але оці
знаєте даже важко сказати що це люди які
наводять
ракети коли вбивають
людей важко їх назвати
людьми вони Агенти російські Агенти вони
це роблять на жаль на жаль наша головна
мета сьогодні виявляти їх і попереджати
всі випадки які можливо до 2022 року
міська рада Харкова от неодноразово
потрапляла в скандали от щодо зриву
декомунізації То були суди щодо
проспекту
Жукова чому це було Тоді питання
проблемним дивіться насправді війна дуже
багато перевернула в ментальності
харків'ян тому Харків до початку війни
ментально і Харків сьогодні - це різний
Харків і нам нам потрібно це розуміти І
сьогодні ми не будемо казати за проспект
Маршала Жукова бо
ті часи сьогодні зовсім
по-іншому і за за інші речі що
стосується закону декомінізації Так ми
сьогодні працюємо над цим ми дуже
виважено
працюємо так змінюється вулиці
змінюється назви вулиць в одному з
інтерв'ю розповідали що поки що вулиці
Степана Бандери в Харкові цитую не
уявляйте хоча от на Харківщині так
далеко в Ізюмі вже і Романа Шухевича і
Степана Бандери вулиці Чи цікавилися ви
думкою харків'ян щодо цих от конкретних
назв як потенційних для вулиць Харкова
безумовно Це кавелс були якісь офіційні
о Давайте таким чином
я менеджер цього
міста мене обрали люди для того щоб я
відстоював їх інтерес
Так у мене є власна думка і власна
позиція яку я можу донести яка доношу
так до людей відкрито кажущо до цьго
питання що стосується цього питання хочу
сказати
що сьогодні підтримки назви цієї вулиці
у Харкові немає ні Шухевича ні Бандери
Ні як гадаєте
чому це це ми доже
повинен знаєте запитати у людей але поки
що не на часі це чому це тому що не на
часі Давайте так давайте я буду казати
за місто Харков Ізюм - це місто яке ее
від Харкова на відстані знаходиться і
Там с
свої громада є територіальна громада там
є своє бачення
всього що там робиться так вони Я
поважаю дуже поважаю все їх бачення але
я буду робити Так так як сьогодні це
вважають харків'яни і Всі розуміють як
потрібно дуже
виважено не дай боже не
виважено все проводити і робити бо це
Харков
і
це дуже така тонка матерія що значить це
Харків я ж розумію харків'ян Я чу чую їх
погляди чую їх думки чую їх настрій чую
їх емоції ее
тому що стосується цих питань давайте їх
за поки що відкладемо на інший час але
все ж таки вулиця в Харкові
перейменовується триває
процес з вулиць Харкова нещодавно
отримала назву на честь лідера
добровольчого підрозділу фрайкор Георгія
Тарасенка так у 2021 у вас був такий
пост де ви особисто писали що члени
фрайкору провели урок у школі з
харківськими дітьми назвали тоді Цей
урок цитую уроком фашизму організацію
пов'язали з нацистами змінили свою думку
Я
особисто знав Григорія Ми спілкувались
вже коли ми обрали миром Ми спілкувались
дуже довгий час спілкувалися під час
війни спілкувалися На жаль я був на його
похоронах і спілкувався
потім потім з
його батьками і
невістою на жаль на жаль Вот і я в
відповім вам Таким
чином Я особисто вносив Цю пропозицію на
розгляд сесії особисто голосував щоб
присвоїти вулицю одну із центральних
вулиць міста на його честь за даними
соціологічного питування рейтингу в 2023
році ви очолили список мерів українських
міст яких найбільше схвалюють містяни
чому інші Мери міст України могли б у
вас повчитися як гадаєте кожний на
своєму місці кожний робить все що
можливе і війна це доказала і я мав без
прецеденту під підтримку сьогодні мерів
інших міст і мерів які наш міста
побратими і не тільки міста побратими і
на і наших міс українських До речі тих
мерів кого я до війни Даже не знав Даже
не знав
мирколамії наприклад який сам
зателефонував потім приїжджав декілька
разів передавав нам продукти харчування
медикаменти ее речі різне Ну я зі всіма
спілкуюсь чи були якісь розчарування під
час повномасштабної війни для вас серед
очільників українських міст е На жаль ее
Були
розочарування серед міст які знаходились
у Харківській області і яких я
знав але
вони на тому боку боці оказалася
несподівано для мене
відверто кажу балаклі для мене це був
жахливий випадок не очікували саме в
Балаклії такч Ні ніколи
ніколи для мене Це було дуже знаєте
вразливо Ну я його знав дуже багато
років покійного мера Харкова Геннадія
Кернеса ви публічно називали другом
соратником у політиці наразі існує
ситуація з його сином Кирилом і
звинувачує вас мовляв було цитую за
захоплення влади в 2020 році
і підробка підпису Геннадія Кернеса у
період його хвороби перед смертю це одна
з його останніх заяв в кінці листопада
Як ви коментуєте ці звинувачення чи
спілкувались з ним про це Я хочу вам
сказати що
е На жаль після того як пішов з життя
Мой друг Я це кажу ще відверто
геннадійшвич
кернос я став секретарем міськоради і
це було рішення депутатського корпусу і
не я
а Верховна Рада прийняла рішення щодо
проведення позачергових виборів
Харківського міського голови на котрих я
здобув перемогу у першому Турі за мене
проголосували харків'яни А якому
захопленні влади має йти мова
ви публічно почали спілкуватись
українською зараз ще є над чим працювати
але почали спілкуватися після
повномасштабної війни що стало о з тим
моментом коли ви зрозуміли Ну все від
Завтра я вже беру за це ні дивиться на
Насправді я
е дуже хотів спілкуватися українською
мовою але е Знаєте до війни на жаль на
жаль так сталося що ми спілкувалися
слобожанською мовою
і тому я хотів перейти на українську
мову щоб
мені не було соромно вам особисто за
себе да так я не можу розмовляти через
слова знаєте слабожанська українська чи
вимовляти щось не так для мене це
потрібно перш за все для мене тому я
хочу
розмовляти справжньою українською мовою
і я дуже моя мета розмовляти справжньою
українською мовою чи відчуваєте що
Харків став можливо більш україномовним
Так звісно звісно Харків набагато став
україномовним І сьогодні знаєте коли ти
ідеш тебе вітаю Доброго дня Чи вітаю
раніш було Здраствуйте привет от Тому ні
і
люди хочуть переходити
хочуть я я бачу молодь вся хоче
переходити тому знаєте я чому тоді казав
що не потрібно наламати дров і дуже
виважена політика повинно бути в усьому
що стосується Харкова а от чи може
місцева Влада впливати якось на
українізацію російськомовних українців
потрібно розмовляти Ну в тому числі
українською
мовою
і це от я вважаю і весь світ вважає що
ми доказали
Харков що ми українське місто і будемо
назавжди українським містом і не
зустрічали тут росіян з цвітами а
зустрічали гранатами миноме
кулями і все крапка Не потрібно це
знаєте кожного разу жувати жувати жувати
ні все ми довели всьому світу що ми
Українська місто ми справжні українці і
потихеньку мова буде ну прийде час всі
передемо на українську мову Як думаєте
скільки років поні 10
років
[музика]
війна наскільки відкинула розвиток
Харкова загалом На жаль відкинула але
дала певні можливості І знаєте я
оптиміст хочу сказати і вважаю що так
дуже серйозні виклики які ми
проходимо вони і дають нам можливості
дуже багато Сьогодні у нас є можливо
разом з міжнародними фінансовими
інституціями з різними нашими
міжнародними партнерами перезапустити
економіку міста зробити місто зовсім
іншим а наразі ось відтік бізнесу
наприклад наскільки вплинув на Харків
Зараз ми чотири хвилі повернення
пережили і сьогодні хочу сказати що от
буквально Вчора ми дивились по
відкриттюфо
у нас позитивна динаміка позитивна ди
плюс 2000 з порівнянням
з до війни А чи безпечно от наразі
українцям які виїхали з Харкова через
війну повертатися у місто кожний для
себе приймає це рішення кожний бо це
його особиста відповідальність безпечна
чи
Небезпечна подивитися скільки прильтов
за місяць було по Києву по льво
По черкасам по тим же і по Харкову
скільки зараз проживає в Харкові людей є
якась от статистика є статистика у нас
1мільн 300 сьогодні перебуває в місто
Харкові і це люди і харків'яни і ті
котрі вимушені були приїхати з
деокупованих територій з інших міст і
областей України Якщо порівняти з
березням
222го року коли в нас було 300 000 і
сьогодні на мільйон більше чим тоді то
ви розумієте що я дуже радий як Харків
планує заохочувати людей які ще не
повернулись Десь ще релоковані
повертатись головне це перше це
безпекова ситуація і ми там повинні це
розуміти е відкриття школ дитячих
садочків наших вишив
є в мене чіткий план дій Що потрібно
зробити для того щоб знаєте залучати
інвестиції щоби залучати підприємців щоб
вони поверталися щоб нові підприємці
поверталися в міста бо конкуренція між
містами буде дуже
велика і зараз є
зараз вона знаєте така скрита
конкуренція всі міста між собою будуть
конкурувати всі
за інвестиції
за кадровий потенціал за людей за все
будуть буде шалена конкуренція і ми
повинні виграти цю конкуренцію головний
конкурент буде ну звісно Київ завжди так
було Київ Львів ці будуть конкуренти
десь Днепро буде у Харкові ви згадали До
речі працює підземна школа метрошкола як
назвали журналист так за анонсовано вже
з січня і метросадочок
е підготовка до метросадочка а буде
підготовка от наскільки проаналізувавши
вже досвід роботи цих шкіл на станціях
ефективність зручність для самих дітей
для вчителів для пасажирів метро от який
цей досвід Ну що стосується пасажирів ми
не заважаємо пасажирам ми так зробили це
що стосується дітей знате тільки
що прово див зустріч оче До речі очень
таку цікаву зустріч яку я мав з людьми
і вони дуже підтримують цю мою тоді ідею
щодо організації
метрошколи і хочу вам сказати на цифри
ви все зрозумієте 1 вересня коли
школяриш пішли до митрошколи їх
налікувалось
десь 890
Угу сьогодні
218 і нема жодного свободного місця а
запит
на міста є Але у нас немає потужності
можливості тому ми сьогодні будуємо
вже і Я розраховую до кінця січня
побудувати
справжню підземну школу на 450 учнів
тобто в дві сміни будуть займатися 900
учнів у у одному районі міста такі школи
будуть з'являтися у всіх районах міста
Харкова до речі девть нагадаю вам вони
будуть з'являтися для того щоби діти
мали змогу повноцінно навчатися а
відбудова Харкова глобальна вже була
зацікавленість доси відомого
британського архітектора лорда нормана
фостера не зацікавленость ми працюємо
вже робота йде не то що йде вона йде
дуже швидки Так є конкретне рішеня
істиційному фонду презентував п'ять
проектів пілотних щодо наукового парка
щодо
вокзалу
щодо центральної
частини щодо житлової застройки До речі
не витрачає
кошти міста Харкова це кошти сім'ї лорда
фостера ви маєте на увазі розробка
генплану чи реалізація розробка
генплана і
нам допомагає дуже німе німецький уряд з
цим проектом а фінансування на відбудову
фінансування міжнародне фінансування
звісно сам Саме місто не зможе все
зробити бо сьогодні знаєте ми
підрахували так приблизно приблизно що
щоб відбудувати все це що накоїл поки
що наш ворог російський агресор 9,5 млрд
доларів США звісно яки бюджет такого не
мо може витримати Тому це міжнародни
фінансове інститут це брд єіп е ще
мировой банк Світовий банк е тому ду
дуже важливо таке потужні банки крім
цього хочу сказати що що стосується
країн то ми маємо безпрецедент підтримку
Німеччини і Я вдячний Я декілька разів
зустрічався і з урядовцями
високопосадовцями е Німеччини і послами
Німеччини і ми маємо підтримку е ми
маємо підтримку яки Великої Британії
сьогодні інших держав і Польща нам
допомагає ви згадували щойно про
міжнародну співпрацю про міжнародну
підтримку українського міста Харків але
от майбутнє України в Європі в ЄС наразі
вирішується в ЄС Ми повинні бути
обов'язково повинно бути тому
потрібно знаєте Прокласти всі зусилля
всі дипломатичні
міжнародне дружні в тому числі стосунки
для того муніципальні До речі стосунки
бо дуже багато впливових мерів дуже
багато впливу
у різних країнах і їх потрібно
використовувати і ми будемо
використовувати все всі всі свої
стосунки всі свої можливості для
найскорішого вступу до ЄС до якого 2024
року ви готуєтесь яким ви його чекаєте
Ну я хочу сказати безумовно знаєте У нас
вже відверта розмова Я повинен вам
казати правду початок року буде дуже
складний дуже складний бо ми ввійшли в
опалювальний сезон є певна загроза
енергетичної безпеки і ми це розуміємо
всі але ми
витримаємо
переживемо бо були Часи дуже
важкі і переможемо Я дуже хочу щоб 24й
рік став переможним для України Дуже
дякую вам за цю розмову
дякую